welcome back everyone to another recap
series I arrived in Iceland yesterday
and today I just played my first round
of the Reykjavik open this is a very uh
very strong tournament very big
tournament it's one of the most renowned
open tournaments in the world I'm the
60-something seed I'll just show the
pairings real quick evanchook is the
first seed there's a ton of grand
Masters here and
um yeah the first round I played a low
raid opponent Tehran Psy colory Hari
from India apologies if I butcher the
name but uh pairings went up about
five hours before the first round so I
actually had a decent amount of time to
prepare let me hide the notation just to
avoid spoilers and I ended up playing an
opening in this game that I've never
played before and I only discovered this
opening
around 3 A.M this morning because I was
really jet lagged I couldn't sleep and
um
this was even before pairings went up
this morning what I was doing was just
playing through recent Miniatures from
Grand Master games and I stumbled upon a
game from Michael blubom uh he was
playing the black pieces he had this
position and he played a move that I
just had never seen before was Knight to
C6 and he won like a really nice quick
game as black and this is uh yeah just a
super rare move against Catalan uh we
can see here uh one two three four five
six Knight C6 is the seventh most
popular move now uh several months ago I
actually played a line Pawn H6 which is
an even more rare line but uh Knight C6
it's still kind of just a surprise
weapon and I'll try and explain the idea
behind this move my opponent developed
normally as you do in the Cadillac and
at first in this position looks like the
Knight and Bishop are misplaced because
the bishop is just staring at these
pawns which are very solid the Knight is
obstructing the C Pawn for moving which
very often likes to move in these
structures
but the point of having the knight in
Bishop here is that there's lines where
let's say white plays Knight C3 black
can take and then very quickly prepare
E5 now after Queen A4 E5 this is one of
the main lines of my preparation
um now we didn't go into this we went
into a different line which I was still
a little bit prepared for after Pawn B3
I played the move Pawn to A5 now I had
this position on my computer this
morning
um this was either a the blue bomb game
or there was another game with on draken
uh this may have been on draken's game
we had the black pieces and there's only
game ever to feature Pawn A5 I'm curious
if this has ever been played on niches
okay I'll have to take that back there's
been over 100 games played on the chess
any games in the Masters database
oh did we break the Masters database
oh no my leechas
oh no it's reconnecting hey we're
reconnected
okay no games and Masters database but
there is definitely a non-jaking game
so what was I saying
oh yeah so the point of Pawnee 5 is to
expand with Pawn A4
and try and create some weaknesses on
the queen side now my opponent played
Bishop B2 I played Pawn A4 this is still
pre-game prep but I didn't really know
much Beyond here uh the only thing I
knew is that if white plays Queen C2 or
Knight D2 black can get away with Pawnee
three and distorted the bishop and later
go for like 94 and F5 and get some
Stonewall setup that didn't happen
because my opponent played Pawn C5 and
this was a new move for me
and I opened the window but the window
is opening further because there is wind
uh let me close it before it gets too
cold
yeah weather is kind of cold outside it
is Iceland in in late March but uh
trying to stay warm
so my opponent played Pawn C5 I dropped
back to E7 and this is another kind of
ugly looking thing about this line is
when white plays E5 it just looks like
white sprouting so much space but very
often B6 will come and I'll be able to
trade off the pawn and that happened
after pawn jig's pawn B6 takes and takes
we got to a position where I am down the
pawn but white has these kind of weak
double A pawns so I thought this was a
nice kind of positional Gambit once I
got to this position I thought the
opening was a success but as we'll see
it was still very much a fight from this
position my point played Knight C3 I
played Knight A5 eyeing the C4 Square
for the night
opponent plays Knight E5 preventing
Knight C4 if I play this and there's
takes and there's this classic pin along
the long diagonal so instead of
blundering a knight I go ahead and try
and trade the knights with Knight D7 and
then my opponents play the move which I
think I underestimated I was aware of
this move but and once he played that I
realized that I might be in some trouble
Pawn to E4 this is a very thematic move
White's trying to open up the center
while I'm still very much behind in
development and if we just see the
placement of White's pieces compared to
my pieces uh it should really benefit
white to open the center now I didn't
irritate the pawn because that would
open the long diagonal and the Beast
would come alive from G2 so instead I
took the nylon E5 and after Pawn takes
Knight I play Pawn D4 so I'm trying to
keep the center closed but in doing this
I am over extending my d-pawn now
there's three attackers against pawn and
the only way to defend it is to move
forward even more so I play Pawn D3
and um yeah I really didn't know what
was going on in this position uh I
decided to enter this because it looked
really interesting and just rich with
ideas but at the same time I'm taking a
big risk because I'm already down the
pond and I might lose this Pawn if I'm
not careful am I opponent play the move
which I didn't quite see coming even
though it's a very natural move Rook to
C1 simple idea Rook C3 and it looks like
White's gonna win the pawn no problem so
I spent some time here uh just wincing
at my position and then I considered a
move which looks really really ugly and
I almost just rejected this move right
away because how ugly it looks but then
I realize it's probably my best try is
to play Knight to B7 retreating my only
or one of my only developed pieces but
the idea is to play Knight to C5
defending and also pressuring a pawn
unleashing The Rook so I was happy when
I I came up with this because White's
still under some pressure like how to
actually deal with the pawn on D3 then
my opponent plays Knight D6 and this is
a very clever move because I can't get
away with taking on D6 if takes takes
whatever I take back with there's E5 and
I'm losing material there's all these
tactics with the diagonal opening up
um
so 96 was a very resourceful move trying
to make both bishops come alive along
the long diagonals ah this window keeps
opening I don't know if I can lock it
somehow I'll have to figure that out
later
but um what happens here oh yeah so
instead of taking the knights I just
ignored the knights and I play Knight C5
defending the pawn
opponent plays Bishop D4 attacking the
Knight threatening to take an angling
the pawn but then I play Bishop A6 so
things are getting even more confusing I
have two pieces defending the pawn
um I have ideas of D2 attempting to win
uh win a rook but at the same time white
has a nylon D6 and we're both kind of in
each other's faces just with this setup
and this setup now the thing I should
note about the situation I had a huge
time Advantage my opponent was already
following below 10 minutes at this point
and I still had over an hour so on the
clock I was doing quite fine but then he
played a move which I again didn't quite
see coming upon A5 which looks like a
very powerful move it looks like this is
going to be the straw that breaks the
camel's back but thankfully I'm not a
camel and I have a strong back and I
didn't panic and I took on D6 with idea
that I'm just getting initiative and
after Pawn dig Z6 Queen digs E6 I'm
hitting the bishop and it seems like the
tactics are working out for black I'm
really curious to check with the engine
because I still don't know what's
happening in this position but my idea
in the scheme is that if light goes for
this move
um or no what am I saying if white goes
for this move then I would take and then
if light wins a rook I'm happy to just
give up the exchange and then we would
get a position like this black has two
connected pass pawns I think black is
very close to winning this position I
might be wrong with evaluation but it
looked very fun to play this from the
back side
so instead of going into that my
opponents uh played Bishop to E3 now
this allows Pond D2 and I'm able to win
material but it's still not so simple
because after Queen D2 we trade Queens I
win The Rook on F1 King takes F1 and
then I'm in the situation where I have
to deal with the issue on the queen side
my Pawn is tied down to defending the
knights nothing's defending my pawn and
there's not an easy way to to solve my
problems here on top of everything my
spreading E5 to hit the rook and unleash
the light squared Bishop so I started
thinking
for a while I probably had about an hour
when we reached this position and I
thought for maybe about 15 minutes
I should know what my opponent had about
two minutes at this point so he was like
already very very low on time and as I
was still thinking he gets up and leaves
the board
now
I was in a weird situation because I
knew he was going to just use the the
toilets and the toilet was pretty far
away so once he left the board and he
was walking like very quickly so I knew
he wasn't going to turn back I I had to
make a split second decision do I keep
thinking and try and calculate
everything
or do I play a move as quickly as
possible and maybe try and go for the
dirty flag as a very weird psychological
moment because it shouldn't be right to
just leave the board when you have two
minutes left and
after having thought for 15 minutes I
already had like a decent idea of what
my plan was so I decided to to go ahead
and like as he was walking away I played
the move Pawn E5 and then his clock
started ticking and it ticked down to
below a minute and he still was nowhere
in sight then he fell below 30 seconds
still nowhere in sight and my heart was
beating fast because I wasn't sure what
was going to happen I probably would
have felt bad
if he were to flag and then once he got
to below about 20 seconds left uh he
appeared from the corner of the room and
used speed walking back to the board and
he got back with um like 10 seconds left
and he was just in time to play the move
King to E2
which was actually not the move I was
the most concerned about I was most
concerned about Pawn takes B6 and I was
going to play 96 here and I think black
is still for choice but it's
I I don't think it's a clear win
um the idea is to play Rook here and
eventually when the pawn or this Pawn
but once you play King E2 then I'm able
to play 96 and get Tempo with Knight T4
check but it still wasn't that simple
because after Pawn digs Pawn I start
with Brooke B8 now both pawns are
hanging
um he's living on the 32nd commit he
plays Bishop to E3
I take on A2 plays King to E1 and now
here it looks really tempting to start
with Knight D4 just obstruct the bishop
and then just go after the pawn like
Rook B2 and take the pawn but I'm pretty
sure Knight T4 is a losing move for
black because white can take take and
then play B7 and I don't think there's
any way to stop rook c8s and there's all
these back rink issues with upon
promoting so thankfully I saw that I
didn't blunder into this line instead I
played King to f8 ensuring I don't have
back rink issues and after he played
Bishop to H3 then I obstruct the bishop
um and here it looks like I'm winning
the pawn except I'm not because he has
Rook C8 takes takes and the pawn is
guaranteed to come to B7 now upon
entering this position I had to be extra
sure that I still have good winning
chances and basically at this point I
had seen until the end of the game
because what ended up happening I start
with Rook B2 of course Pawn B7 and then
check on C2 trade the bishop for the
Knight and once I saw that we were going
to get this position then the winning
idea for black is actually quite nice I
very simply walk up with the King and
White's completely stuck and eventually
White's gonna be in some sort of zuzuang
position where White's just going to run
out of moves and have to self-destruct
and as we see what happened in the game
I start with Rook E3 Chase the king back
walk my king up and white was just
waiting I got my king to D4 and slowly
but surely White's just running out of
moves at some point the King has to walk
away from E3 of course if the bishop
removes I win the pawn
so I got my king all the way in
reinforced G5 played Rook B2 and in this
position it's Wong white either has to
abandon the F Pawn or the B Pawn uh
opponent played a few more moves Queen's
actually on B8 but then my Rook comes
back
and I Target the F Pawn
actually here there's a nice kind of
waiting move Rook to C1 which prompted
resignation from my opponent because
it's another situation white just has no
good moves if Bishop G2 I would play
Rook G1
and then the King has to move like he
will get into F2 and it's just paralysis
for white in this position
so yeah uh Rook C1 was the final move
opponent resigned and I got the first
round win
um it was a crazy game I'm really not
sure what was happening in the opening
um
I'm really curious to check with the
engine but at the same time dinner is
closing in a half hour and the
restaurant is like a 15 minute walk away
so I think I'll leave it a mystery what
the engine says I didn't even have time
to check it uh before recording this
recap but if you're curious what the
engine says I will leave a link to
Alicia study in the video description so
you can analyze the game on your own and
be sure to stay tuned for more Recaps uh
don't forget to subscribe I'm gonna try
and post Recaps throughout the event uh
there are eight more rounds I think
there's a good chance I'll play a grand
master tomorrow
so let me get out of here thanks for
watching and stay tuned for more